after the honest trailer check out the
honest theme song and music video we
made for the jurassic world franchise
link in the description below
[Music]
from the studio living off toretto fumes
and minion juice comes hollywood's most
reliable franchise because every new one
is worse than the last
jurassic world dominion how do these all
make a billion dollars
dinosaurs have spread throughout the
entire world off camera in between
sequels dinosaurs are in our world
because colin trevorrow knows what you
really want for the epic conclusion of
his dino trilogy
locusts
locusts altered with cretaceous era dna
these locusts in nebraska are about to
wrap it up
and while the same old dinos did the
same old things
the big new addition to the franchise is
bug stuff the locust prehistoric dna has
made them stronger than they should be
yes nobody said there be bugs they did
not yet here we are what's locust
mandibles wings thorax
do they they know that bugs aren't
dinosaurs right
look out because everything you hate is
back like chris pratt who's appearing in
six major releases over just 12 months
go away
claire the ass kicking roof jumping
dinosaur fighting survivalist and if
you're asking wasn't she a white collar
executive just a few years ago
the original cast is back too laura dern
shines and pairs of increasingly
high-waisted pants as the most beloved
actor of all time because who else could
overcome this dialogue he slid into my
dms no
jeff goldblum a chaotic wise ass who's
taken a job just for the money playing
ian malcolm a chaotic wise ass who's
taken a job just for the money well i
got five kids you know so uh expenses
add up and the triumphant return of dr
alan grant who triumphantly returns
after he triumphantly returned for
jurassic park 3.
alan welcome back old friend alan
welcome back
alan
no one was stupid enough to build
another dinosaur theme park but one
corporation was so dumb they built their
apple store in dinosaur canyon are there
um
dinosaurs in the mines mirror dinosaurs
everywhere there plots the evil ceo
dodgson remember dodson dodson we've got
dodson here who along with the scheming
doctor wu of course not him it's always
him has a plan to capture maisie the
clone a girl suffering from you're not
even my real mom you can't keep me here
you're not my mother and i'm not even
real mom besides i'm not even a real
person anyway to take a tissue sample
from her body that could cure all human
disease i'm sorry but that sounds
extremely worth it i wonder they kept
distracting with locusts
that's
bananas
so instead of staring in awe while your
jaw drops in wonder stare grimly at the
empty burned field the franchise has
become as they scrape the scrapings off
the bottom of the waste barrel at the
barrel bottom recycling factory with the
obligatory bigger t-rex giganotosaurus
biggest kind of the world has ever seen
obligatory evil science company i might
have made it seem as if bioson wasn't
rotten to the core and obligatory
divorce stuff it's over
oh i'm sorry to hear that
on top of newer tropes like the
obligatory lack of chemistry between the
leads
obligatory girl with one line about
being gay that's easy to cut out for the
china release and obligatory moment
where you can stop any dinosaur from
attacking by making the stop sign with
your hand
staying out of trouble
hey no
hey
come on colin you know that only works
on blue because owen trainer from birth
to follow hand signals you should know
better you wrote all of these
every
single
time we all act surprised
starring
owen great e for effort bryce dallas how
have they not asked me to take over
these yet homeschooled kids are weird
thank you for your fan service
steve knob wu is for the children han
yolo
lupin the turd did the dinos have large
talons
and the world according to jeff goldblum
jurassic world
not a fan
jurassic world episode six the clone
wars
what is that saying uh we're three meals
away from anarchy
if we don't stop them
you can pick your last three meals
what what are you talking about what
what what what what what what what what
what what what what
thanks for watching and if you made it
this far watch our honest theme song for
the jurassic franchise click the
thumbnail on the right to watch now
poor unfortunate souls in pain
in need a baby ocelot should be called
an us a little tell me about it stud